hillary clinton remember her she was the
woman who said that donald trump was an
illegitimate president she said it many
times in interviews uh she still got a
tweet up that said it um she's the woman
that just passed out remember just like
two weeks before election just dropped
dead and they hid that they dragged her
carcass into the thing and said she was
fine
you know she probably killed a couple
people you know hillary you remember her
she was married to bill bill of course
is the guy who took a uh cigar and
actually stuck it up an intern while he
was on the phone uh in the oval office
uh with he was calling trent lott and he
uh well you know this is a daytime show
i don't want to tell you everything
anyway hillary clinton's back and she's
very worried about democracy people
because she is democracy
like palpatine's the senate take a look
i believe you said it's up to us to make
sure the plot stays fictional after
writing this any interest at all in
getting back into the game of politics i
will never be out of the game of
politics i'm not going to be running for
anything but i really feel amy and i
know
george was interviewing adam schiff
before
i really feel like our democracy is at
stake and there's many reasons for that
some of them we saw on
the screen with the insurrection some of
them because of the revelations about
facebook that creates a world of
disinformation instead of you know one
that we can agree on what the facts are
i really am worried about what's
happening at home and around the world
so i'm never going to get out of uh you
know being
involved worried and hopefully trying to
help in some way
you know they say wishes come true but
it's obviously not true because like
many times wished that she would just
disappear and yet she keeps reappearing
so you know i'm gonna have to switch to
another birthday wish uh but there's a
lot of nonsense that she just said there
okay so she's never going away she's not
gonna run and it's like yes you guys
never going away is why we have this
problem uh we've got 137 year old dianne
feinstein as a senator here in
california everyone knows she's
basically incapacitated at this point i
mean that's like an open secret at this
point uh you know biden is 78 and
obviously has problems nancy pelosi is
an alcoholic how old is she 80 whatever
she is it's like just let go people
forgetting that i have political
disagreements with him just let go trump
is old too so i'm not making this a
partisan thing but but the boomer
generation has to let go
they're the first generation that
refuses to just let go and let the next
generation in
the gen x people are supposed to be
running the show right now the 45 year
olds are supposed to be running the show
i don't want to run the show but it's
supposed to be people roughly my age by
the way rhonda sanses i think is 43
years old just saying yes nancy pelosi
is 81 but hillary says a couple
interesting things right there our
democracy is at stake this is the woman
who said that the previous election uh
was illegitimate that you know the
orange man was illegitimate but you know
she gets a pass on that um but the
democracy that's sake why is it at stake
well there was the insurrection and that
is true for three hours a couple people
were cosplaying and larping and went to
the uh capital and had no weapons and
you know it was put down they had no big
plans and you know that was that um so
that did happen i cannot deny that that
happened uh also facebook facebook's
coming for democracy now look you know i
have no love for big tech but facebook i
mean you saw everything that happened
with this ridiculous faux whistleblower
last week who's really a leftist
activist and the idea that facebook is
destroying democracy went in many cases
not that i sit here to defend mark
zuckerberg very often
but zuckerberg made an interesting point
last week we're basically the only one
that's doing any self-reflection trying
to figure out what we are doing we're
doing all of these surveys we're talking
to people we're trying to figure out how
to how to de-escalate some of the
political madness now i don't know if
it's working i don't even know if that's
true but it's obvious that facebook is
at some level trying to
somewhat moderate what is going on on
its platform look at twitter which is
just an endless
um
an endless cesspool of insanity
uh that's what twitter is they're not
doing any of that right so
that's not to defend facebook but
hillary is very concerned about the
insurrection and she's very concerned
about facebook now interestingly when
she says that our democracy is at stake
she doesn't seem to be concerned that
the federal government would be
attacking states rights she doesn't seem
to be worried that we're forcing people
to make medical decisions that they
don't want to make she doesn't seem to
be very concerned that the economy is
tanking right now that inflation is
going through the roof that gas prices
are really high that a lot of people
can't afford to buy houses right now as
the housing market keeps rising and
people are losing their jobs
i don't think she meant any of that when
she said that she's worried about the
state of democracy hmm
i'm gonna have to i'm gonna have to
think about that you know what
i'm gonna have to think about that